[Music]
what you're gonna learn in his talk is
first of all what's cloudy HSN and why
would you use it and then I'll talk a
little bit about some of the new cloudy
HSN features that were we're announcing
today as well and then afterwards Matt
will come on stage and take and explain
to you about customer management
Christian keys and explain how it works
and how you leverage customer management
Christian keys to help meet your
compliance requirements now at the end
this talk I I can pretty much guarantee
that you'll learn something new at least
one thing and my only ask of you is that
you please do not fall asleep these are
really really comfortable chairs and we
need you to pay attention okay so
forgive me if this is going through some
of the things that you may already know
but I always find it's useful to kind of
level set and talk about you know what
are the options that we have available
today so we have a wide spectrum of
different ways to do encryption of your
data arrest in our Google cloud and so
by default we encrypt everything and if
you've ever talked to me before I'll
tell you that we're not going to give
you a choice you have to encrypt your
data arrest and there's no option to
turn off Google was the first cloud to
do this where it just became automatic
thing and if you do nothing then we will
make sure that it's encrypted at least
one layer and we'll do all the key
management and everything else inside
internally through our own internal kms
system now you can also use cloud kms
which were introduced a few years back
to actually go and create your own keys
and with those keys you can support
something called customer management
Christian Keys and what that allows you
to do is that it allows you to leverage
the data arrest but protect that data
arrest use using a key that's under your
control in cloud kms okay and because of
the work that we did with cloud hsn.the
you can use both cloud kms and cloud hsm
keys synonymously okay so you can
actually use this to actually protect
data with your keys and cloud cloud HSM
and then finally we have customer
supplied encryption keys so this is
something that we provide for support of
both GC and GC GCS
what this meat what this feature does is
that when you go and try to you know
access your data you have to provide a
secret along with your API call okay and
so we don't persist that secret which is
necessary to unlock the data and so for
that reason you know we if you don't
access the data it's it's really really
really hard for us to actually get
access to anything now the one thing
that I just want to point out about that
is that it's only available for GCSE and
GCE and you know a good reason for this
is that we really don't have access to
that key otherwise and so if we don't
have access to key we can't do things
our offline like compaction or logical
backups or anything like that so it will
only be for those two services now
what's an HSM how many people here use
an HSM okay good actually I would say
over half of you so for the other half
an HSM is a hardware security module
it's basically a physical device that's
used for managing and perform encrypt
operations okay now there's a lot of
reasons why people use these they you
can create keys are nonce portable and
the hardware device will provide certain
guarantees prevent the keys from being
exported or exposed and there often
provides some guarantees around tamper
evidence and tamper resistance so things
like if you try to extract the key it'll
be something that you'll be made aware
of and in the extreme cases if they
can't potentially zero out the keys as
well so that the attacker can't actually
get access to anything and the the final
thing there is is that they're often
FIPS 140-2 certified tips one point - -
is a certification from nist that
basically defines crypto modules and so
it covers everything from the
implementation of algorithms to the way
the random number generator is random
numbers are generated and everything
else most times people are using these
devices because they either are very
heavily regulated and so these things
are often helpful in getting through
your compliance auditor or they're
required to protect high-value keys so
financial institutions for example are
very very big on these things now what
we've done with cloudy HSM is that we
provide the managed service on top of
these devices
so for the other half who have actually
had HSN s you know that they can be a
little bit challenging sometimes to
actually manage and so we have taken
that burden and we match everything to
the point where all you see is an API to
do the key management and do key
generation encryption decryption things
like that right and so there's really
nothing for you to do we actually manage
it and we fully scale it right we do
Auto patching we do the the backups of
the keys everything so there's nothing
for you to do now one of the things that
that you may be asking is that why would
I use our Cloud HSM well compliance is
again a major motivator for this we are
using HSM Center FIPS 140-2 level 3
certified right and so that may or may
not be important if you if you don't
know what that means then you probably
this doesn't matter to you but if you do
care then you know that level 3 is sort
of the gold standard that everyone
everyone looks for now and you can only
achieve level 3 through hardware devices
you can't do this through the software
regionalization so one of the
interesting properties of the service
that we've created is that when you
create a key in our cloud HSM service
that key is cryptographically bound to
the HSM s within that region so if you
create a key in say US central one then
only those HSMs and US central one are
able to actually go and use those keys
and perform crypto operations ok it's
just that there's a there's a strong
binding cryptographically between the
keys and the devices themselves we we
will eventually support a global region
and we're working on multi regions right
now but currently we have this deployed
in several regions across the United
States and Europe and for those people
who are already using cloud kms then
there's actually no changes necessary
it's the same API that's just one flag
when you actually create the key and
then everything else exactly saying I
should have mentioned earlier that if
you need to ask any questions please
feel free I have a little bit of hard
time seeing because it's so bright but
just wave your arms wildly and I'll
probably see you ok great
now I want to make a couple
announcements one is that cloudy HSM is
generally available it was actually
generally available you know a few
months ago but in case you didn't know
it's it's g8 now so if the GA label is
important for you then you had it right
now and more importantly we have the
Singapore region live so today we have
it available in three regions across the
United States
qu and Europe and now we have one in
Asia and we're rapidly increasing the
number of data centers that we will be
supporting and you should see in the the
near future that will be coverage
covered almost everywhere that you
expect cloud to be okay oh and one more
thing I'd like to also announce that key
import is now available in alpha okay so
with this you'll now be able to lease
for the Alpha to import your symmetric
keys into our cloud HSM ok and be done
in a very secure manner where you will
not have to worry about the keys being
exposed now one in the beta will expand
this to support other types of keys and
import into the software but for now you
can actually import this into the HSM
and the way that it works is that we use
a method called well it's a pkcs 11
method so just forgive me Forbes a brief
moment where I step into a little bit
more technical jargon but we're using
the RSA AES key rap and essentially the
way that the process works is that the
hsn's will create a public/private key
pair with the keys on the private key
only available within the HSM so we
don't have access to it and then you can
export that that public key take it to
your key management device and then on
your key management device you would
have to do this process called AES key
wrap and essentially the process says is
that your key manager would have to go
and create an AES key to wrap your key
or the key that you want to import and
then the public key that you just
downloaded would wrap the AES key and
then you take that and bring that back
up to our cloud and then our eight then
our HSMs are able to unwrap everything
all within the HSM boundary
my name is Matt risk Lima as I said the
beginning I'm product manager and I
focus a lot on customer manage
encryption keys so what is ce mec CEMEX
a feature that allows you to control the
encryption keys that are used to
purchase
the your data arrest in Google cloud
this is a really really important
feature if you need to show control for
regulatory or compliance reasons over
the protection of your data we'll talk
in a second in a little more detail
about where this is available on GCP
today but just very quickly it's
supported in bigquery compute engine
participant disk in cloud storage and in
our data proc product so how does seem a
quark actually to understand how CMAC
works you first need to know a little
bit about how encryption at rest works
within Google
so Ilsa I mentioned at the beginning
that we provide default encryption at
rest for all of all of your data in
Google cloud so we'll start there when
we provide this default encryption at
rest what we do is we take data as it
comes in and we split it into small
chunks each of those chunks of data is
then encrypted with a data encryption
key then that data and it's encrypted
data encryption key is distributed
across Google storage infrastructure and
stored so when you come to Google and
you decide that encrypt default
encryption at rest is sufficient this is
generally the scheme that we use so when
you use C Mac we're adding essentially
an extra layer into this each chunk is
still encrypted with the data encryption
key but then that data encryption key is
wrapped with a KMS key
we call that KMS key the key encryption
key so what will happen when you put the
data to rest is the service that is
storing your data will call out to kms
it will wrap the data encryption key
with the KMS key that you've indicated
and then it will store the encrypted
data encryption key and the data chunk
in whatever storage system it's using so
there's some interesting properties of
this that are really really useful for
compliance the most important is
auditability so every time that we put
data to rest we actually call out to kms
and so you can get a data access log and
a log of the encrypt or decrypt of the
data encryption key and you can use that
to go monitor access to your data
through our key management system also
to the services that use kms for CMAC
it's transparent if the key is in H at
HSM or if the key is in software so all
of the sort of value that you get from
Cloud HSM is available with the same
configuration that you would use for a
software key this is really powerful
like we actually provide totally managed
make it totally transparent to you the
customer then we have HSM s behind the
scenes protecting your data
so what are some best practices for CMAC
there's two things I want to highlight
first is regional alignment when you
actually go to configure CMAC you'll
notice that some of the services will
only allow you to configure keys that
are in the same region as the resource
they're protecting we push customers to
do this for resiliency and for latency
and it's occasionally a place where
folks stub their toe if they don't know
this constraint and the second is
separation of duties so how the services
that store your data talk to kms is
through a service account when they use
that when we provision that service
account on your behalf or we we have
tools to do this for you when you create
CMAC protected resources in the UI we
give that service account a very minimal
set of permissions it only can encrypt
and decrypt with the kms key so when
you're using kms in general we encourage
you to think very deeply about what
permissions are actually needed for any
given principle accessing kms and keep
those permissions to a minimum so CEMEX
support on google cloud today we support
CMAC across four services I don't want
to give you some detail about it and
bigquery we support C Mac at the table
level so anytime you create a table you
can indicate us see my key and we will
use that see my key to protect the table
and bigquery in data proc we support C
Mac at the cluster level that Seema key
is going to be used to protect the
persistent disks that are in the cluster
we also allow you to indicate a storage
bucket and that storage bucket can be
protected using ce mec as well and so
implicitly cloud storage also supports
ce mec and we support C Mac as a default
key at the bucket level or as an object
level Sima key when you write an object
and finally persistent disk support ce
mec per disk so maybe we will move to a
demo this is a dis o'clock AMS you know
page on on the cloud console and when
you want to create an HSM key it's
really really simple right all you have
to do is essentially what I call the
keyring I called it this so I just want
to make sure it coincides with my little
script so when you create a keyring all
you have to do is specify the key ring
and then make it a region now for HSM
keys you have to make it in the regions
at HSM support and for example US West
one is currently support
right so that's that's great then what
you need to do is you know you basically
have to go down and choose what kind of
key so you can do things like I can
create an asymmetric key for example for
signing and when you actually do that
you get a choice of all the different
types so you can have now when we say
symmetric key here a symmetric key here
specifically means aes-256
in GCN mode right but you know for
signing you could get to choose whatever
you like and so I'll just pick let's say
ECP to five six right and then I go and
say that I want create this in the hsm
and then I'd say create a live a key
name so you know like my demo ace and
key or something like that right
it doesn't really matter and then you do
that and then it goes and creates and
that's it right so if you ever work with
hsn's before you know that creating a
key takes law steps here is just one
flag and now you have a key available to
you every time you use that key all the
operations will be performed within the
hsm the key was created within the hsm
and it's ready for use with the kms api
now now that we we have that we have
that keyring and everything else I'm
going to show you how to use the key
import feature that's an alpha now it's
an alpha there's no UI associated with
this so you have to do it through either
API or g-cloud so I'll do it through
g-cloud because that's a little bit
easier so there's a couple things I have
to do to set the environment I need to
actually set an alias it's it's an alpha
so you have to download a private
version of g-cloud right just hold on a
sec they kill all that and then let's
see I will just create that and then
this authorize it okay
okay so now we're all set up right and I
probably need to actually go and SEP so
remember I told you earlier that we're
gonna use a little shortcut to actually
do the encryption and wrapping all
within g-cloud and so in order to do
that you need to actually install the
Python crypto cryptography library right
and I should have already done that here
unless the reboot actually screw
something up hopefully I'll keep my
fingers crossed if not then I'll I'll
just have to redo this all right now I
create the keyring already and so the
first thing I need to do is I need to
create an import job an import job in
our language is basically this an object
that represents the import key right and
so that job is basically import key now
this import key is going to create a
private public key pair like I said you
can download the public key and it'll
exist for three days and so you can use
that public key to import as many keys
as you want for three days afterwards
really helps create a new one okay and
so if you look at the syntax here please
let me know if it's too small it's a big
screen I think your guys are okay so I'm
creating a US West one under the same
keyring the next 19 demo keyring one I
just created up there and protection
levels HSM that's a flag that tells it
that I want to create this into HSM
stuff in software and then I specify the
import method now this method there's
two of them there's this one the RSA OAP
302 72 sha-1 AES 256 and there's the
same one with with a 4k key okay and so
you this one I'm just going to use it
with a 3 K 3 K key so hopefully that
goes through fantastic and then what I
will do is that I'll list it out there
so that we can see the cue that the
import job is available right and so
it's there it is right there so you can
see that the demo import job is there
it's active and the type of method it is
so we're all set now now the next thing
we need to do is that you know you can
actually go and also see the public key
so you know if you
if you were to do this like with your
HSM you would need this public key and
so here's a pen file you can just copy
this into a pen
you know import it and off you go now
what we're gonna do next is that first I
need to create a crypto key and so if
you're familiar with our key kms already
you have different constructs you have
that keyring you created you have the
keys which is actual the container for
all the different key materials and then
you have versions under these each of
the keys right and so I'm just gonna
create a key because I'm going to import
a key version and put nothing in there
so that's all I did right here I just
created a key with nothing in there
and then I'm gonna generate a symmetric
key I'm gonna do it the really really
easy and quick and very very official
way which is to use dev random okay and
I'm just going to get 256 bits and put
them into a into a temporary file and
then after that I'm going to run the
import job now this is where it's gonna
fail if the if the cryptography
cryptography package was installed for
python but hopefully that's still there
and if you look at the command right now
it's same thing location keyring you
specify the key that you're trying to
import then the tark then the target
file where the actual key is and then
you know the import job and algorithm
which is symmetric keys okay so there we
go okay see it didn't work because this
stupid thing reset okay so I need to go
and actually do sudo pip install sudo
pip install whoops cryptography and so
this is probably good for everyone here
to know if in case you want to do this
so that I think you have to do this and
it works so all I'm doing is I'm
stalling the proper Falls the reason I
need to do that is that this whole RSA
AES key wrap is available in this
cryptography module not in not in Python
by itself whoops I'm sorry I meant to go
up one more now I do the import job
and should work and there you go it
imported the the key and so you can see
that you know it told it explains that
to symmetric-key
what time is created what project and
that it's enabled and this is show you
that this key actually works and just
remember that the key that created is
called demo import key one you can see
right there I will go and do a test
encryption so you know this one's really
really simple actually I don't I'm not
going to use the txt it's just I'm going
to create a text file that just says
hello world right and simple as that and
then I'm going to run the standard you
know kms API 2kms commands to actually
do the encryption so you can see right
here all I'm doing is that I specify
that you know alpha came as encrypt in
the location West keyring everything
else and then I just give the cipher
file and it's going to export to chem CT
okay and so if you look at MC T you see
that it's just basically gibberish right
it's cypher text and now if I want to
actually take temp C CT and I want to
actually know decrypt it using that key
because it's a symmetric key right I use
the same key for encryption and
decryption then you'll see that it works
it says hello world so there you go
that's that's all you have to do to
import a key into into the HSM it's now
in there okay yeah the question is this
is key visible in the console yes it is
so let me go back here real quickly and
let me refresh this and so there you go
it says not available because I haven't
defined what a primary key is right but
I mean I I imported that key it's
version one and so you know you can
still use as long as you specify the
version if you want to use it this
without the version then you need to set
that as the primary key okay all right
let me turn off the mat real quick so
that he can do is demo now that we got
this working so you know the demos are a
lot more entertaining
the question is do I have a time line
when this is give me GA not exactly
right now I mean I don't expect to take
too long to reach GA but for now I mean
we're looking to get some feedback in
the Alpha so I encourage you to actually
go and try to sign up for the Alpha test
it out and if we get enough feedback and
we'll be able to go quickly through the
beta NGA process thank you
the question is would this be the same
process during GA or would it be more
integrate with console definitely you'll
have more UI with this the way we do
things typically not always is that in
the Alpha releases we don't normally
have UI support but during the beta
timeframe will have full UI full support
all that stuff
Google's definition of a beta is a
little bit different than when most
people really think of as a beta our
betas are typically fully supported and
we'll have full you know the things are
usually locked down everything else
anything else we're using a vendor name
caveum yes anything else perfect how's
it going Matt good we're all ready to go
alright I'll turn over to Matt he's got
very interesting demo so for my demo I
kind of wanted to check as many CMAC
boxes as possible in ten minutes so what
we're gonna do is we are gonna take a
public bigquery data set that is word
counts of Shakespeare's corpus we're
gonna take that as the input data into a
data proc job that will react Gate it
across and aggregate not over the each
shake work of Shakespeare but each
across the entire corpus so we'll get
the word count across the entire corpus
when we do that we will make sure that
the bigquery table it goes back into is
protected by C Mac the data proc table
is going to be protected by C Mac and
all of the intermediate files in GCS
will also be protected by C Mac and for
fun we'll make sure that it's an HSM in
London that's do
the protection because British stuff so
to start I'll show you
oh I clicked on the wrong button one
second I'm just going to show you the
input data whoa uh to start I've been
show you the in put data it with a safe
bigquery query so I have the saved query
in bigquery which I I'm gonna open the
query in the editor and we'll see what
the input data is and we can see well we
can see that by court by each work
Hamlet King Henry how many words there
are so now we're gonna go over to km/s
and we're gonna create the CMAC keys
that will protect our job so this is a
little bit of a different create path
than ill song so demo live we're gonna
put the key in europe west to which is
the London region we'll call it the key
demo and we'll make the protection level
hsm so we'll create this now we will go
to our storage bucket and so we're gonna
create a storage bucket to store the
intermediate the intermediate output of
the job we'll call it demo live so now
we want to protect the stored storage
bucket with an HSM key this is really
really easy to do I just choose I put
the storage bucket in the same region as
my HSM key I go to my Advanced Settings
and I go to my Advanced Settings and I
use a customer manage key when I go to
this drop-down I now see the demo live
key that I just created I can choose
that and what's happening here like we
talked about earlier is I'm getting a
prompt to grant access to the service
account that represents this bucket so
now the GCS service account has access
to camp
that's pacific KMS key for encrypting
decrypt so i'm going to create this
bucket
I will go back over now to data proc and
create a new cluster so as before I put
in Europe West - I'm going to use mostly
standard configuration but then under
Advanced Options I'm gonna choose the
cloud storage bucket demo live and I am
going to add some metadata that actually
allows me to okar that's cat helpers so
I I would add these into the metadata of
the cluster to create the job which I'll
skip because it's a little coffee pasty
and then I'm gonna choose a customer
manage encryption key so when I choose a
customer manage an encryption key just
like before demo live will be asked to
grant access to the service account it
takes a little bit of time to spin up a
data Park job so I'm not going to do
that live right now instead I'm going to
show you how this works for the job I've
already created so now what's happened
is I've created it I've created a HSM
key I've created a cloud storage bucket
to store the key and I've configured
that data proc job to actually use our
HSM key and so you'll see when I
actually submit a job oh and the last
piece sorry and I'll show you this after
I run it but in the last pieces in this
in this Python script that's going to
run and actually do the aggregation I
have there is a line that indicates when
it creates the destination table and
bigquery to use a MS key to also protect
the destination table and bigquery so if
I run this and the demo gods are on my
side we should get an output
all right so our jobs running we're
coming down to the wire on time here so
hopefully it runs fast so you see that
output of the job we're actually getting
word counts out which is great and now
we're ready into bigquery you can see
that jobs running and the jobs complete
so let's go back to bigquery and I'm
gonna look at my word count output and
I'm going to query this table and I'm
just gonna select star from big cow from
the output table and just for fun I'm
going to say where word equals math you
see how many times I appear in
Shakespeare and did--no rows three times
so now what we just did is we actually
read data at a big query we pulled it
through a data proc job that process the
data we wrote that output back to
bigquery and all of the intermediate
data and the output was protected by
CMAC so now to prove this to you I'm
gonna go over to the cryptographic keys
again and then this key was using not
demo live demo Europe West too and I'm
gonna select this key and I'm gonna
revoke everybody's permission to use
this key oh wait sorry info panel
so like we said there were service
accounts that can use this key it has
two members I'm gonna remove these
permissions and I'm also going to remove
the permission for a key that is
protecting the bigquery data set and in
the meantime I'll show you that that key
was cat fur count up high and we're
gonna just grab four key so in that file
we had a destination KMS key set that's
the key that was on the bigquery table
and so now we will try to rerun this job
and it should hopefully fail
and in the meantime we're going to go
back over to bigquery run this query
again Oh give it a second for the
permissions to update all right well
we're down to the last thirty second
great so you see permission denied on
KMS key so now because we protected
everything when KMS we can use KMS as a
way to control access to the data so we
have 47 seconds left so that's about it
for the demo any last-minute questions
yeah yeah it is
yep so this could have all been we could
have used the key that he also created
and I would have been able to do all of
the same things so it's pretty powerful
right like in about five minutes we just
sort of created a bunch of keys in an
HSM you could import your own material
if you wanted to I can use those keys to
protect both the intermediate steps and
the outputs of a data processing job
that spans three or four Google products
right so this is compliance across a
pretty relatively complex pipeline in a
few minutes and a couple clicks so yeah
with that can we slip out flip back to
the presentation for one minute all
right so the takeaway so we make Google
Cloud makes managing encryption easy for
compliant sensitive workloads this few
things we really hope you take away
today are cloudy HSM Allah is simple and
scaleable access to Hardware protected
keys including importing your own key
material cloud kms makes enables easy
management of all of your encryption
keys regardless whether or not they're
in an HSM and then CMAC enables you to
control encryption across all G not all
some GCP services very simply to achieve
your compliance goals thanks very much
[Music]